ça pouvait représenter combien d'argent
par jour pour son proxénète à son petit
ami venu sans mal par claire
au parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu
as envie d'autre chose nathalie baye
j'allais à l'école et en même temps je
faisais ça donc c'est comme l'argent de
poche pour moi tu avais d'autres potes
qui faisaient ça ouais tu avais peur ou
tu te disais de façon je suis mineur je
m'en fous mais voilà c'est chimie n'a
hélas pas de risque donc c'est ça donc
en fait tu te disais je m'en fous car d4
avait traduit tout ouais ouais combien
de fois deux fois c'est le foyer et ont
lâché au bout de combien de temps 96
heures et celle d'autrefois 24 heures
non c'est pas de l'argent facile m quand
tu fais de l'argent facile pas du tout
mais quand tu fais des tp de 10 heures
quand je fais de tp de 10h à minuit des
temps plein des temps plein mais quand
tu fais de 10h à minuit et tu prends ta
paire minuit je te demande pas que tu
vas te rendre le surnom merad l ademe
haddad m alors on va on va pas vous
plaindre adèle merci cela soit réussi là
où il ya des gens qui travaillent à
l'usiné du corail 10h et qui gagne 1200
euros par mois et travaille comme comme
des chiens je suis sûr vous gagnez pas
1200 euros par mois a même deux fois
plus deux fois plus on est content mais
il dit les faibles mentalement parce que
c'est la facilité qu'il a choisi moi
j'ai grandi entre les fossés gens les
morineau la cité du luth pour ceux qui
connaissent j'ai passé 28 ans dans un
quartier égal chaque fois que j'étais
travail à 15 ans et demi les mecs ils
m'ont dit arrête de faire coincer fûts
de bière tu fais pitié viens avec nous
pour d'idées pour faire le show à
l'époque c'était mille francs mille
francs par jour c est moi je touchais
5100 francs c'était que dalle c'est en
cinq jours je pouvais faire mon moi
mentalement moi j'avais envie d'y
arriver mentalement je voulais que mes
parents ils soient fiers mentalement je
voulais garder je voulais faire les
choses tout seul est la facilité c'est
d'aller faire les choses comme il l'a
dit lui lui voulait das a cédé ça c'est
facile de le faire faut pas dire tout à
l'heure il a dit il ya moins de risques
il ya des risques de prendre une balle
dans la tête les mecs faut pas dire aux
jeunes n'y a pas de risque vient
déranger les jours qui suivent quand je
te dis c'est la facilité et je veux
faire chefs d'entreprise tablent de
droite un de jambes faut aller
travailler
[Musique]
damien tard elle est avec nous c'est
incroyable cette image à un moment
qu'est ce qui fait que vous vous dites
je vais mettre une gifle au président je
vous dis hein les gilet jaune sont
exfiltrés ces gens là sont des
travailleurs qui ont parfois deux fois
mon âge qui ont peut-être pris sur le
temps de travail pour être présent ici
et pouvoir s'exprimer ils sont exfiltrés
par la police tout ça pour éviter de
faire tache sur sur des images télé d'un
président qui en fait en campagne à
leurs frais mais c est à un moment où
vous dites c'était prémédité votre geste
non pas vraiment je vais penser
peut-être cinq minutes avant mais jamais
j'ai pensé qu'il viendrait aussi pressé
minutes avant vous êtes dit que m magic
le président et je suis dit pourquoi pas
si il vient aussi près de nous n'est pas
terrible mais damien vous dit pas un
moment c'est extrêmement grave ce que
j'ai fait
c'est juste une gifle vous avez vu que
le président n'a pas porté plainte oui
oui j'ai été condamné par le préfet de
la drôme qui a démissionné le lendemain
de sa plainte mais bon vous avez vu
quand même que le président n'a pas
porté plainte c'est quand même c'est fou
oui après il a quand même porté plainte
pour une caricature lui en hitler non
mais là on est lointain peut viser il
n'a pas porté plainte ben oui c'est de
la magie condamné à trois de prison sans
qui porte plainte
non non je n'ai aucun degré n'avait
aucun regret non derrière après il ya
des mots qui vont dire regarde l'autre
il a giflé macron il fait le buzz et des
chanonat et savage if la polio non
s'agit d'une invitation à cette
attention tu es un guignol mon pote est
un guignol moi j'en l'épreuve est une
brèche
j'ai envie de vous excuser auprès du
président ont écouté ça serait une
double humiliation que de m'excuser
d'avoir mis une gifle quand même en
l'absence de 14 ans qui s'est suicidé le
5 octobre dernier après avoir été
victime pendant deux ans d'harcèlement
scolaire c'est un déchirement le 5
octobre dernier
votre fille est ta soeur ryan ces
suicides elle avait 14 ans j'ai vu de la
lumière dans sa chambre il voulait
rentrer pour la la grande et lui dire il
est 2 heures
et en fait
quand honda chambre à droite et à son
lit à gauche et à la revoir donc à
droite elle n'était pas dans ce money et
j'ai juste tourner la tête et je les
trouvais
accroché à son placard
avec une ceinture
j'ai essayé de
de la soulager en fait je les ai pris
les les jambes et j'ai appelé mon mari
qui est venu en courant qu'il a décoché
qui a commencé les massages cardiaques
mais elle était déjà morte et en fait
elle a fait une première tentative au
mois de mars
donc elle s'est retrouvée à l'hôpital
pendant une semaine
et
elle recevait enfin que quelqu'un lui a
envoyé un message en lui disant
on espère que la prochaine sera la bonne
là tout est raté mais t'inquiète pas la
prochaine sera la bonne le collège m'a
dit mais c'est très grave il va falloir
porter plainte et moi je voulais dit oui
je le portais plainte contre les parents
des de ses filles et contre le collège
est en fait d'un moment où j'ai dit
contre le collège ça c'est un peu comme
moi oui voilà alors ma fille elle a
repris après son hospitalisation elle a
repris les cours et ça a été encore pire
qu'avant c'était encore pire qu'avant
parce que elle me disait même la cpe
maintenant j'ose même pu passer à côté
d'elle parce qu'elle me regarde de
travers où elle rigolé sur son passage
avec les autres les filles donc à elle
sans brevet avec mention très bien est
lui 410 sur 400 donc c'est un objectif
dépassé j'ai tu vois malgré ton année de
merde tu as quand même assuré elle était
aussi traiter de sale intello parce
qu'elle posait beaucoup de questions en
classe
les élèves ne supportait plus en fait la
supportait plus quand tu fais pour aller
de l'avant aujourd'hui je vais pas de
l'avant j'y vais pas
elle me manque chaque seconde que
j'avais fait ma soeur me manque
on s'appelait tous les soirs
vous montrer comment elle et sabine
lendemain pour aller en cours
on est des lunchs times n'a pu saler
lunch times ont mangé ensemble en amphi
stan vu que j'habitais pas à la maison
quand ça allait pas ma mère me demandé
de l'appeler je l'appelais se confier à
moi
j'essaie de rentrer le maximum les
week-ends et les vacances je passais
tout mon temps avec elle je faisais de
la musique avec elle on écrivait des
chansons chantées
je suis désolé rayonnante mais france
excusez moi
non t'excuses pas export
rien aujourd'hui c'est quoi ton combat
pour
rendre justice à ma soeur dans un
premier temps je veux que ce harceleur
et c'est harceleuse el pais il paye
c'est pour ce qu'ils ont fait ils m'ont
enlevé ma soeur ils m'ont enlevé ma
soeur j'ai plus de serge en avait qu'une
seule il me l'a enlevé les jeux qui paie
pour ça
assia donc cette jeune fille qui a été
prostituée à 14 ans toutes les deux
jennifer assia se bat depuis pour faire
bouger les choses tout a commencé à 14
ans aujourd'hui vous avez 17 ans je
crois
quand vous êtes tombée amoureuse d'un
garçon là il avait 17 ans vous avez 14
ans et au départ vous êtes gentil
attentionné c'est ça bout de combien de
temps il commence à vous demander
de faire des choses un peu curieuse j'ai
envie de dire
en fait ils sont en fuite ou les deux du
coup la fût que ça coûte de l'argent
ouais donc c'est plutôt ça va mais s'est
présenté comme un petit revenu spontanée
ponctuelles pour payer l'hôtel payer à
manger
un don qui donc ils lui disent pour
qu'on s'en sorte tu te prostituer oui
puis en même temps ils amènent aussi sur
le sur le sujet que si c'est lui qui
fait quelque chose d'illicite il risque
la prison et comme il a déjà commencer à
la mettre un peu sous emprise et
l'isoler ci lui va en prison qui sera là
pour elle donc c'est comme ça que
commence côté un peu machiavélique de
l'emprise je vous entendiez bien avec
assia tout se passait bien oui alors les
cas ça se passait bien sauf que moi
j'étais en train d'effectuer une peine
d'un an d'accord une vieille
condamnation de 2013 que je découvre en
prison que votre fille
se prostituent mais aussi tuer alors il
va complètement la coupe et sa famille
de tout en même temps avec l'argent
qu'elle gagnait sur les passes par
exemple il s'est permis lui offrir les
bagues de fiançailles de lui mettre la
bague au doigt avec ce qu'elle avait
gagné avec ses fesses quoi il était
capable d'être jaloux de ne pas la
laisser avoir son téléphone de faire le
mec possessif tout en la laissant faire
dix clients par jour et où m excusez moi
des termes et des vieux gros dégueulasse
de 65 watts et
pédophile quoi les 15 ans et un bébé ça
pouvait représenter combien d'argent par
jour pour son son proxénète ancien petit
ami devenu ce procès devient semble pas
recueillir
les permis leur parle du coup je suis
monté à paris la chercher en fait en
faisant passer pour un client je les
trouvais voilà en bref je vais ramener
avec moi à toulouse et cette première
fois on a été ensemble ce faire elle
s'est fait expertiser a physiquement
donc il y avait elle avait des lésions
des ecchymoses une tuberculose latente
elle avait la gagne 1,8 mais creuse
l'étude pour la sortir de là en fait
donc nous arriver c'est quelqu'un qui a
un garçon qui a été la chercher
c'est un garçon qui a fait le client et
qui est ressorti de la chambre avec elle
pendant un mois et demi deux mois on a
franchement elle se reconstruit un petit
peu et reflets 60 et enfin moi je
croyais qu'on avait vu le début du bout
du tunnel est en fin de compte je
n'avais pas anticipé que
oui mais il est revenu à la charge par
les réseaux sociaux il est rentré des
ronettes ouais il est rentré alors en
contact avec elle je vous avais fait à
ce moment là mais je me suis pas aperçu
de sa et l'emprise a repris puisqu'elle
m'a volé ma carte bleue et qu'elle a
fugué pour le rejoindre de nouveau
me dit baisser les bras même mon mari
tout le monde a vraiment tout le monde
me dit de la chose à faire mais je peux
pas du coup je prends mon fils de 8 ans
et je monte à paris d'accord vous
remontez paraguay la houle a retrouvé
nous venons là sur le coup je la trouve
pas en fait je sais à peu près où aller
mais n'arrive pas à la trouver plus tard
est un tout petit peu en contact avec
son frère n'est pas un tout petit peu ça
fait que je sais qu'elle va bien enfin
qu'elle est vivante surtout en fin de
compte parce que je sais rien de plus et
elle a plus confiance en moi parce que
c'est de l'éloigner de ce mec donc pour
une résidence une autre côté ludique
faut pas que tu retournes et que tu as
d'ailleurs si je passe par quelqu'un en
qui elle a confiance qu'elle connaît
puisqu'elle était enceinte de quelques
mois d'ailleurs d'un prix d'une passe et
je passe par quelqu'un qui l'a fait
revenir tu l'as fait revenir dans le sud
en lui disant je vais m'occuper de toi
fin voilà si le papa de nom donc côté un
criant c'est pâques ans et j'ai
l'impression de redescendre par ses
propres moyens en fait parce que si elle
revient pas et qu'elle reste en fixe son
enfant sera placé à la naissance il ya
donc elle revient en fait sans que vous
interveniez d'ici propres roe toujours
pas ma mère soit là que c'est moi qui ai
payé son billet tout mais comme je suis
pas dans l'accord et elle a l'impression
que c'est vraiment elle est en confiance
on est donc là elle elle revient pas
aujourd'hui vous avez vous avez un
enfant donc de quel âge tiens moi je dis
moi il s'appelle comment quel
[Musique]
village à l'époque j'avais 22 ans et lui
il en avait il allait y avoir quatre ans
il avait 13 ans 13 ans elle fait 14 ans
l'aviez-vous non tous les deux vous
aviez une vie intime oui je bats la
suite de ça je suis tombée enceinte de
lui et je suis parti sans lui donner
d'explications alors c'est vrai que sa
rousseur rougerie est ce que vous
comprenez que ça parce qu'on a gagné
autant de oui ah ben moi s'est écrié me
met extrêmement mal à l'aise déjà c'est
pas parce que ça existe qu'il faut le
mettre en avant dans une émission de
témoignages c'est pas non plus une
émission d'information
et puis ensuite ce qui m'agace c'est que
le ton de l'interview est
particulièrement bienveillants parce que
c'est une femme j'aurais bien voulu voir
ce que ça aurait donné ça a été un homme
deux ans quatre années j'ai mis en
france est une fille de 13 ans tu meures
dexter pédophile c'est la vérité il ya
plein de cadeaux qui font leur première
fois à 13 ans il suffit d'un accident
sur la première fois 13 ans pour que la
personne en face effectivement tomber
il a 13 ans donc et voilà les gens qui
font ça non non ça ne me choque pas non
mais mathieu en fait je suis donc pas
ton avis vu que je donne mon
en 16 ans j'étais avec quelqu'un j'ai
commencé d'ailleurs à 13 ans et c'est
une relation très sérieuse avec qui je
reste cependant problème qui était
malgré que tu étais minaj et des noms on
avait le même attrait de change tout m
delphine pardonne moi un garçon pourquoi
pas précoce c'est l'amour avec une jeune
fille elle aussi précoce mais ils ont le
même âge c'est pas la même problématique
là ce qui pose question c'est qu'on a
une jeune fille a une personne qui est
majeure au dessus de l'âge de la
majorité avec quelqu'un qui est en
dessous y compris de la majorité
sexuelle est un genre une différence
d'âge après l'amérique d'accord avec
mathieu ll est hors la loi parce qu'à 13
ans il ya c'est un détournement de
mineur et donc c'est très grave après
c'est le co le côté je suis tombée
enceinte vous ça veut dire qu'elle sait
pas protégés c'est à dire qu'à pas de
pilule ça veut dire qu'à pas de
préservatif donc on tombe enceinte comme
ça bon ben c'est pas grave après tout en
tendance est comment va dans un magasin
où on va au fast food et puis après on
se tire parce que bon après tout c'est
pas grave on part donc on fait un enfant
comme ça puis après on aille à celui de
père en fait on dit responsabilité
aujourd'hui on fait des enfants comme ça
mais ça je trouve que c'est super grave
les dalton ce collectif lyonnais qui a
commis plusieurs mais fait qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à tous ces gens qui disent
que vous êtes des hors la loi et
qu'aujourd'hui vous devez être puni
probablement
pas vraiment encore une fois il n'y a
pas de blessés à chaque chacun selon ses
statuts quel est votre responsabilité
messieurs je peux pas être responsable
mois d'un mec qui fin je vais droit mais
son un truc comme ça c'est pas moi qui
ai créé l'euro des couleurs les accents
de revenus d'emplois en dix ans voyait
position me se faire reconnaître si on
veut pouvoir parler aux pouvoirs publics
si on veut si on veut contester une
décision de justice est d'en faire un
vidéo et qui on s'habille en dalton nous
cette solution jusqu'ici demain est un
gamin qui frappe à votre arrivée vous
donnez une moto non justement on s'est
ainsi déjà rivés justement je voulais en
venir c'est qu'il ya des gamins qui
viennent justement nous demander
j'aimerais bien par faire partie du
collectif voilà je peux faire si je peux
faire ça non justement on n'a pas besoin
on n'en veut pas va à l'école en
demandant d arrêter par an on est on
sait dès ce pays depuis dix ans ça veut
dire qu'on a tout la police qui est là
dans un contexte de reconquête de la
république ou je ne sais quoi donc c'est
la faute de la police en fait si vous
avez un petit peu ok madame quand vous
faites contrôler toutes les cinq minutes
qu'on vous met en prison pour le moindre
acte en lui serrant la main gauche est
rodé au cyanure douceur la loi nre
d'évitement parle alors que jusqu'à
présent
on est les victimes de la police à
l'émeute à des victimes madame on assume
totalement justement on est prêt à
chaque date on est prêt à payer la peine
de enfin à purger sa peine telle qu'elle
est wima d'après l'emblème à vous êtes
encagoulés souplesse aux
jeux du chat d'alice est d'entendre ce
que vous voulez entendre ma dalton et si
vous disent on est entièrement d'accord
pour vous recevoir mais vous enlevez
votre déguisement de dalton et je vais
vous n'êtes sans crois moi je devais y
aller
parce que ça change je repars comme ça
je vois pas ce que ça change de voir nos
visages ou pas en fait sur le mouvement
s'est massé partie des gens parce que ça
peut changer en faisant gilles grapinet
a pris goût à cette centre de seniors on
n y était pas du tout non n'y a pas pris
goût parce qu'elle malgré malgré tout il
ya des conséquences alors les peines et
tout s'est pas non plus rien du tout ce
qui se passe qui est en train d'arriver
appartient à certains de nos collègues
qui sont actuellement incarcérés c'est
hors contexte et c'est pas normal
vraiment c'est il fait sa peine serre
qui purge sa peine mais on vous parle
d'endroits s'acharner sur la même ça ou
lala lala êtes pas dans les coulisses et
moi ce qui se passe est une réalité qui
est là et qui est vrai et en gros ce que
je trouve que ça sent totalement du
contexte chacun il est incarcéré purge
sa peine ok on va pas aller le sache a
ni sur lui
par exemple alan bonus du clip c'est un
mec qui la loue la lamborghini son nul à
saisir si on est là ce qu'ils veulent
pas la rendre il a quoi avoir le mec qui
fait son business qui loue des voitures
qui fait tout ça en gros en plus
légalement pas bien il a qu à voir dans
cette histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le personnel 6 et senans je vous dis ça
fait un carton il est sorti cette
semaine tout le monde m'en a parlé moi
ton va dire ce que tu as vu ce
documentaire ce que tu as vu
documentaire j'ai donc bien sûr regardé
et j'ai pris le parti de vous inviter ce
soir fonds marco od pas à vous dit vous
vous saviez pas ce que c'était en fait
l'histoire non j'ai vu dans le
documentaire on savait rien de tout mais
vraiment rien non mais moi je suis un un
ferry ce voile est un jour chaud restant
comme ça et je vois des belles voitures
passer à une équipe m'a donc je me suis
dit qu'est-ce qui se passe sa clause à
l'i way et je vois un mec qui s'appelle
my sweet qui est mon ami et je le vois
descendu très belles voitures et
judicaire tu fais en ce moment il m'a
dit tout va bien donc j'ai pris un
billet je suis parti quelque part dans
un pays et j'ai vu que ça se passait
très très bien et là j'ai attaqué j'ai
avancé
voilà je
ce québécois de l'argent l'épuré moi je
savais que j'allais me faire arrêter
ouais donc j'ai dit plus gens dépensent
vous êtes fait arrêter à temps
alors le problème c'est que moi je me
suis mis en cavale ouais à cause je me
suis mis en cale parce que j'ai pris 8
ans j'ai pris le maximum ses dix ans
donc sur huit ans je me suis dit mot la
prison va m'attendre faire ce que j'ai à
faire des gros admire bas sur les huit
ans ils sont la mémoire tient à rome et
puis vous avez pris une photo de voir
rome et puis après vous avez été
rattrapé en six ans j'ai fait le tour du
monde madame haman a fait le tour du
monde ou du monde j'ai voulu savoir qu
en cavale est ce qu'on pouvait faire le
tour du monde on ya un mec moi qui m'a
dit un jour avec le co2 on arrivait
parfois affaire de chiffres d'affaires
500000 euros par jour non puisque ça
puisque ça aurait beaucoup puisque ça
plus tard oui mais un million mais
hormis lyon et vous et vous êtes-vous
resté combien basse * vous alliez ça
dépend
ça dépend
si tu es petite chose raconté
téléspectateurs une histoire qu'on m'a
raconté sur toi est ce que c'est une
légende ou pas une histoire de pato
merguez
dans un restaurant qui n'en faisaient
pas et tu leur demi je veux des
partenariats ce que ça
c'est vrai chez ducasse c'est ça ouais
alors racontez nous l'histoire c'est
quoi eh ben je suis arrivé j'avais tu
sais quand tu vas en boitant envie de
sortir tu as envie d'aller manger ouais
et puis j'avais envie de manger des
pâtes aux merguez way et le problème
c'est qu'ils avaient pas de merguez
cacher ouais je mange casher enfin halal
casher separate est important que des
ouais bien sûr que c'est important que
je me dis que je veux pas remettre de la
saucisse est ce que tu veux
et je leur ai demandé et je l'aurais
laissé quitter chez ducasse il veut pas
dire le nom sacré dû faire de la pub
c'est un très grand restaurant étoilé
et j'aurais demandé d paterberg et ils
m'ont dit il y en a pas ici des pâtes
aux merguez on comprend pas c'est quoi
les pattes hors mariage judy et 10000 tu
fais des pâtes aux merguez team is wrong
way il m'a dit combien geof
sinon
[Musique]
voire d'être avec vous aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup alors tout le monde vous
attendez on était tous comme des fous de
vous recevoir très heureuse donc merci
d'être là
c'est la traduction attendu que
c'est mon devoir est tombée amoureuse de
lui à 12 ans c'est ça c'est qu'il en a
déjà trois à douze ans on avait 23 ans
il en avait 23 vous avez partagé sa vie
pendant 21 ans
c'est ça mérite et rémy il avait 23 ans
de comporter j'ai partagé
pas partager notre quotidien vous dites
je l'aimais et en même temps vous dites
aussi c'était un type dont j'avais peur
il y avait un double visage c'est à dire
il y avait le pablo à la maison et puis
pablo escobar celui qui faisait peur à
tout le monde je l'aimais c'est
suffisant pour ne pas dénoncer
tableau était le père de mes enfants
et en colombie il ya une loi
ne peut pas on ne doit pas dénoncer sa
famille quoi qu'il en soit moi j'avais
très peur j'étais complètement paralysée
face à l'horreur et ge avait extrêmement
peur de perdre mes enfants justement si
je faisais cela est-ce que pablo était
un homme à qui tout le monde obéit c'est
alors parce que vous aviez vous avez des
enfants est cuit en 77 vous étiez encore
au lycée quand vous avez mis au monde
juan pablo votre premier fils étant 84
vous avez ensuite une fille manuela
c'était quel genre de père pablo escobar
première partie de sa vie au cours de
cette première année dont je viens dans
l'eau était très présent avec juan pablo
justement à cette époque là il a mené à
l'école participé aux réunions avec les
parents d'élèves en fait c'était un père
tout à fait normal qu'ils rêvaient que
son fils fasse des études de décembre
1993 pablo vous appelle par téléphone
mais vous étiez sur écoute ce qui a
permis de géolocaliser son repère une
opération ensuite est mené et pablo
escobar perdra la vie abattu par la
police colombienne
ce coup de fil il doit rester dans votre
tête
oui absolument
asthmatique il fallait pas que je m
occupe qu'il était en train de faire
tout son possible pour que nous
puissions une fille en fait qu'il
l'avait toujours fait
c'est une question que je me pose qu'est
ce qu'il faisait alors pour
nous permettre de vivre dans le
bien-être alors que en revanche toutes
ces actions généré beaucoup de haine
contre nous voulions vous l'êtes ça
oui il ya beaucoup de douleur on hamm
est ce que c'était mais m mais là c'est
certainement pour maison maximum de la
mort sont nés qui sont le fruit de
l'amour
le rêve d'avoir une maison ensemble et
toute l'horreur
aussi bien eux que moi même et tout le
pays avons dû vivre pardon est ce qui
vous est le site de l'argent ou et de
coûts élevés vous aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ne nous a pas laissés d'argent
des biens sont revenus à l'état
colombien et sur qui les agglos quant
aux ennemis de pablo
lorsque nous avons eu les pourparlers
que nous leur avons remis le reste des
propriétés parce que moi je n'ai jamais
été en contact avec son argent je n'ai
jamais subi de la légalité et donc gelé
remis aux ennemis ce que j'avais
vous savez il ya un vieil adage en
france qui dit à rome fais comme les
romains donc à rome on fais comme les
romains à au maroc on fait comme les
marocains mais je suis
alors rachida merci d'être là rachida
vous êtes devenu une star aujourd'hui
tout le monde ne parle que d'eux
pourquoi avoir accepté de rencontrer
raymond va pouvoir m'exprimer tout
simplement ça lui ses idées ses idées
vous font peur non non non parce que
c'est vraiment des extrêmes c'est des
idées extrêmement donc c'était vraiment
pour avoir le personnage en face ils
vous en allez vous avez vous l'avais
trouvé sympathique j'ai l'impression aux
élections oui mais c'est ça qui est
grave estime louis sympathique mais
triste avait fallu sortir de trois
quarts
on dit que vous ne portiez pas le voile
pour porter le voile depuis quelque
temps puisque certains sont allés sur
votre compte facebook et ont vu que vous
ne portiez pas le voile allons le porter
depuis neuf mois c'est ce qu'a dit jean
marc marino depuis le début de l'année
quoi à tout casser d'accord qu'est-ce
qui a fait que vous leur portez g voilà
après c'est une question de foi mais je
les dis
j'essaie de me retrouver dans ma foi et
je commence petit à petit oui disent en
sélection et qui ont du concours à la
mise en scène ce qu'ils se sont dit
tiens elle portait pas le voile avant on
a été voir sur son compte facebook elle
portait pas le voile est maintenant le
porte peut-être que c'est le compte
facebook raconte toutes nos rêves
ignatius 4 mai mais je vous dis voilà
donc voilà les éléments personne qui est
sorti exactement elle le port depuis
neuf mois donc voilà il ya des malades
sur la loi justement pas glee il
interdisait le port du voile est ce que
du coup vouloir de février où est ce que
vous seriez le pays qu'est ce que vous
feriez vous n'aviez pas nommé en
imaginant c'est une question a permis à
raison voyez jamais qu'est ce que vous
feriez je le portais pas avant quelques
mois ça ne m'a pas empêché de travailler
d'accord donc là si on devait nous
l'imposé 6 à 2 il ya un texte de loi qui
devait voilà tiens vous êtes une femme
vous devez pas porter le voile
j'appliquerai la loi comme tout le monde
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]